on revient sur cette saga du déversement
de 8 milliards de litres d'eaux usées
dans le fleuve saint-laurent ne s'est
pas terminée mathieu dion s'attendait à
une réponse d'environnement canada
demain matin du côté de la ville on
apprend que rien n'est joué
voilà après que tout ça est éclatée la
ministre de l'environnement du canada
leona aglukkaq a demandé davantage
d'informations pour donner son aval à ce
projet de grand déversement
or ce qui a soulevé l'ire du maire de
montréal denis coderre est bien c'est
que environnement canada était au
courant du 2 au 6 depuis septembre 2014
or la mairie de montréal s'est pliée à
la demande de la ministre et voici ce
qu'on a reçu samedi dernier
environnement canada a toute la
documentation depuis hier soir et ils se
sont engagés à tout lire en fin de
semaine et nous donne une réponse au
plus tard mardi
ça c'était samedi de la ville de
montréal or aujourd'hui de la part du
bureau des ministres et non
d'environnement canada et on a reçu
personne ne s'est engagé à quoi que ce
soit à ce que ce soit terminé mardi les
scientifiques d'environnement canada
prendrons tout le temps nécessaire pour
examiner et analyser en profondeur
l'information qu'ils ont reçu de la part
de la ville de montréal
alors il semble bien sûr que tout ne
soit pas jouée à l'heure actuelle est ce
que ce sera est ce qu'on aura une
décision avant les élections 19 octobre
ça reste à voir mais elle prend le temps
presse parce que les travaux doivent
avoir lieu normalement
à compter du 18 octobre et ce pendant
une semaine pour faire les réparations
sur cette chute à nages ce qui entraîne
la fermeture d'une canalisation et ce
dès versement de 8 milliards de litres
d'eaux usées et la pression populaire se
fait de plus en plus forte et une
manifestation de kayakistes et de surfer
ce week end
également il ya cette pétition en ligne
qui a recueilli plus de 90 millions
jusqu'ici qui sera présenté demain soir
au conseil d'arrondissement de ville
marie très bien mais parions que la
décision ne sera pas prise avant le
scrutin de lundi prochain le 19 mars qui
devait commencer le 18 commencera
vraisemblablement plus tard au vert
merci mature on va suivre ça de merde
quoi merci au revoir